[Music]
this is an interesting painting and I
want you to just take a look at it
for a few seconds before we talk about
it I've looked at this painting a
thousand times I use it in my classes
I've seen it in art museums when it's
been on view and there are so many
subtleties but one of the assumptions
that I made not as an art historian but
just a viewer of art is that what I was
looking at on the plate was a piece of
meat like a piece of ham with an eye in
the center and when I first showed at
one of my classes I said okay who's
gonna tell me what they say and someone
raised his hand and said that's a big
old pancake on the plate and I would
have never considered that it was a
pancake is it a material distinction
maybe maybe not but he was so sure that
it was a pancake and I was so sure that
it was a piece of meat while it might
seem like a really subtle distinction
it's not if you if you think about
something like I witness testimony well
he was wearing a red sweater no he was
wearing a blue sweater that's a big
difference and one of the things that
reminded me of the Magritte painting
there was a crime scene in Texas and
they were speaking to a witness and they
said what did he look like what did the
what did the suspect look like and the
witness said he had a cowboy hat on so
everyone was looking at in Texas lots of
people wear 10-gallon hats so they were
looking for a suspect with cowboy hat on
well it turns out suspect was wearing a
Dallas Cowboys cap so the choice of
words it wasn't a cowboy hat it was a
Dallas Cowboys hat the idea of saying
what you see and being sure about what
you say
that's how communication lines can get
crossed and another interesting thing
about that Magritte painting that i
found fascinating one of the wonderful
things about writing a book is people
write to you they read your book and
they send you their own observations and
I received an email from a woman who
said has anyone ever told you when they
look at that painting and describe it to
you that the fork to the right of the
plate
is turned upside down and the tines are
facing into the table I'd never noticed
that looked at the painting a thousand
times
and again material difference no
critical no important yes it's one of
those details because if someone said to
me describe the silverware in the
painting I would have said you have a
knife and a fork and sometimes it's
those very small details of the tines
facing the table that can bring a whole
case together or crack a case or be that
one detail that brings all the other
pieces together
[Music]